[Music]
fronts are this week sorry you it's all
ready to go and then I was like and I
looked at my actually looked at my
calendar and they went it's not gonna
happen
it'll be bad if it happened so yeah but
how it's gotta be weird to not be at
upfront though if you're that you're the
creator and the showrunner yeah sort of
yeah they're gonna give you a pass on
that one yeah they they I don't think
they expected me to go no because it's
you know it's more about other shows
that are premiering right now mm-hmm but
you know they invite everybody and but
my cast is go or my main cast is gonna
go so right an Elgin the guy I'm doing
the prize right with is gonna go yeah
yeah it was not Bend so it's all you
know yeah it's new for him right this is
his Freight is this he's written other
stuff but this is his first like big TV
show yeah ya know he's a super talented
guy he just had we doing it we're all
roll right into it he's doing Elgin
James he's in a movie come out this year
and I'm gonna forget the name of it
lowriders maybe uh-huh but which he
doesn't like to talk about because uh
not unlike what happened with me and
southpaw
they uh you know you know bunch of there
were changes were made yeah changes I
made much to his dismay so right um but
now he's a super he's a really talented
cat it's like one of those things where
you know that experience where you're in
a good way you're in a room with
somebody when I first met with him and I
you have that realization of like oh
this guy's way smarter than me you know
what I mean like just you know just
operating on that different level and
and obviously very much a different life
experience you know I mean he's kind of
from the culture isn't he yeah he was uh
he was a guy who came up and you know
straightedge right and you know some
people call them gangbangers and he had
a different perceptive perception of
what they were doing and you know he is
just like the hardcore scene right yeah
ii DC and and you know he he was a punk
rocker right now so they traveled all
over the world and kind of they would
leave little nuggets behind and as a
result their organization grew and
became somewhat worldwide and you know
then after 9/11 all those organizations
got classified as terrorists right and
and it just went a completely different
direction and you know he ended up doing
some time and you know for what he
believed in and but really just a solid
guy and loyal and super smart and it's
like rigidly like you know those dudes
that have that kind of focus yeah and
just go wow you know yeah I know he's uh
he's friends with my boy John Joseph
he's from that from that world as well
he knows he knows everybody yeah like
I'll you know I'll walk into crossroads
you know yeah and well that's like the
mecca for all hardcore like you know
Toby Moore's yep he's part of that kind
of and and I know Travis really where I
usually go and meet Travis there and
every time I go Elgin is there with
somebody else you know I mean like some
other player you know it's weird because
it's such a fancy right you know fancy
vegan restaurant where like all these
super intense like hardcore straightedge
punk rock guys that's like their
Clubhouse it is it's it's really good
and I know you had Travis yeah
I love that dude enjoy he's amazing he's
an amazing guy and I just like you know
I try to have lunch with him at least
once or twice a year just to you know
get a little bit of what he's got you
know what I mean and it's so funny last
time I had lunch with him his dad
brought his dad along and I go how about
that it was just sort of like my dad's
in town and he and his dad was at the
table and you know it's a first you're
like okay what what's the debt like how
do I and then like he's just he's just
so real and like so open that within 10
minutes like you know is that just
became part of that dynamic and didn't
say a whole lot but it was sort of like
wow that's like I don't know if I would
have the capacity to trust my own you
know social interaction skill to drop
somebody into that situation who did you
know what I mean and then just
incorporate them into the whole
conversation right without it being like
a lot of like work beforehand yeah yeah
and and and you know and then you you
embrace it and then by the time you're
done you're like he just took a you know
he made it a completely different
experience without intending to did he
like like what do you mean by that just
by it by like gate providing this space
for his dad to just you know lately it
was just there and it was yeah and and
and and his dad you know a really sweet
guy and and didn't chime in much and and
you know we the Travis would go out of
his way to include him when you know
when it made sense but it was just you
know it was just like oh we're just it
was like oh I'm just sitting here with a
member of your family yeah and you and
in us engaging in him being part of it
so that you know I realized that it you
know it I had to make the adjustment in
terms of like not thinking that I had to
then change how I interacted with him
that you know what I mean yeah so it
made it a different experience for me so
that when I was done I was like oh that
was that was really you know that was
really cool that was that would be a
situation that normally might make me
uncomfortable like oh how do I include
this guy and because you know Travis is
just so bloody there
yeah and real and his dad just kind of
the same way that it was like you have
no choice but to kind of let it become
what it's supposed to become you know so
that you know by the end it was like
well that was awesome you know but there
was no like oh you know I guess what I
go to is trying to do that with my old
man like when he was living just would
be a different it speaks to you know
like look your Travis is a you know he's
a sensitive artist but he's very he
knows who he is and he's totally
comfortable with that yeah he doesn't
he's not he's not gonna try to make
other people you know feel like go out
of his way to be somebody else to make
other people comfortable right but to be
able to embody that in a tricky social
context there's another thing right yeah
and just you know I guess cuz it's often
you know parental inclusion into things
can be a loaded dynamic routes and the
fact that he loves his dad and and this
is just part of his day you know it was
just sort of that energy and you're like
oh okay that's that was just that you
know his dad was here and his dad is
going to be part of his day
whatever Travis is doing today dad will
be part of it uh-huh and I was part of
that thing you don't again and I just
you know I just I was like I couldn't do
that one mile man I want to hear more
about that but before we do that I I
think like it's interesting you bring up
Travis because you guys are mean you're
very you're very different people but I
but there's similarities that I see in
you guys in that you have this kind of
public persona that's all about like it
served like a tough guy you know I you
know I got things figured out
and you know don't cross me you know
arms cross kind of thing that Travis has
but then you talk to him and he's like
the sweetest guy and he wears his
emotions on his sleeve and he like you
said he's totally present and and with
you like because I've known you as long
as I have you know and I know you
outside the context of Hollywood
I see like your public persona and I see
kind of what you put out you know hood
on Twitter and the like and that's
changed that's evolved certainly like I
want to explore that with you but
there's such as to me I'm like these
look like two different people because
the Kurt I know is like this really
sweet kind giving presents family guy
dad you know husband you know always
always there you know to be of support
or with a hug and and then I see like
some of the you know some of the spats
that you get into that end up you know
turning into these things and it's like
he's like wait who's that guy you know
yeah yeah I would say that no no no I
would say unfortunately they both are me
yeah meaning you know I worse you know
but I will say that I you know you know
I used to lead perhaps a way to say it
is I used to lead with that right I used
to lead with you know my very accessible
anger right and because it worked for me
right it sort of was creatively it's
sort of what I was known for and and and
then after a while and yes it definitely
got me in trouble on more than one
occasion but also it's exciting it's
exciting and I left you know and and for
better or for worse that's you know
people remembered it right but then I
think what ended up happening is I just
just got boring you know and because of
what ends up happening is you think oh I
have to then when you get to the place
where
you feel like you need to sustain it
yeah or drum it up that's when you
realize now it's [ __ ] you know and
and I think I just reached that point
where I I wasn't you know perhaps that
angry anymore or I didn't have to push
back as much because I had you know a
track record of success yeah so I wasn't
constantly you know in warrior mode and
then so and you know and then I realized
well I can't that's to sort of lead with
that then becomes [ __ ] well becomes
a character then exactly
nej my perspective on it is that yeah
what's your perspective well it's
probably much better than mine you know
look at times it was salacious and like
I said it was exciting but it was always
rooted in truth like you were you were
in a certain respect like it was it was
speaking truth to power like it was
always like coming there was always like
some aspect of what you were saying was
something that needed to be said and
something that that a lot of other
people also observed but for a variety
of reasons just we're never gonna say
that thing you know like you would you
would you had the balls you have the
courage you had the you know maybe
shortsightedness at certain times to go
hey wait a minute like this is [ __ ]
well you gotta call this out so it
always felt like it came from a genuine
place it thought it was you know but
there's a there's a like stirring the
pot thing and I think you know to
contextualise it like that was probably
early mid sons of anarchy
when you're trying to make your stamp on
the world and but you know trying to
make sure that people were kind of
seeing this project that you were
birthing in the way that you wanted it
to be seen right yeah I think that's
true I I mean it was never it was never
disingenuous right it was never like
[ __ ] you know there were times where
I definitely you know intentionally you
know
yeah you know and and you know and and
poked a few eyeballs right but it was
never it was always rooted in something
that I felt strongly about and I think
what happened is that I felt comfortable
enough or perhaps I was careless enough
to you know rattle that cage and say
things that perhaps other people may
have felt but wouldn't necessarily yeah
either have the balls or perhaps you
know we're too smart to say so that was
you know that was definitely part of it
early on and it was always you know you
know anger was always a survival tool
for me right so it was about challenge
you know channeling that piece of me
into you know into something that
perhaps could serve me better than
throwing a fist at somebody right so and
you know it definitely you know
definitely got me into trouble some you
know early on but it create a lot of
notoriety - yeah and I can't deny
attention what's you know there's like
you would tweet something and there'd be
a whole like nikki Finke would write
like a whole article about it be some
deadline piece write what you said and I
think when I got to the place where I
felt like that became disingenuous right
where it was more about you know
drumming up controversy then really
perhaps whether proper or improper
speaking out about something I really
believed in you know not that I wasn't
aware of the impact it would have but I
think what happened is I got to a place
where I was just sort of like do I
really believe that or is that me just
trying to you know is that me reading my
own press clippings and thinking I had
something to sustain yeah and that's
when it sort of like and you know like
anything else you you I don't know if
you know mature maybe too strong of a
word but you realize that you don't have
to work so hard at it anymore you know
and I think that's what happened to me
is that people understood who I was
people there was you know respect for
what I did and I didn't have to swing so
hard right to to do what I wanted to do
you know and and not that I don't
occasionally take a punch now or swing
at something because I do but I think
you know over time it just I had to take
a look at well what is you know what is
me when am i trying to just be
controversial for the sake of being
controversial and when am i using my
notoriety so at the very least express
something that you know upsets me or I
think is is dubious or whatever yeah I
mean I've noticed that you're not afraid
to speak up when something moves you I
mean you you wrote a piece about Harvey
Weinstein you wrote a piece about like
the Google anti-piracy thing like there
are moments that you've chosen where
you're like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
speak my piece on this you know you did
a thing about on the eve of the Trump
election or on the in the wake of that
but like I checked your mean used to
write a lot on your blog and like I
think the last entry on your blog was
like 2013 yeah like you just cut that
off you know what happened is is really
it's the power of Twitter and and just
became a much more powerful tool
you know then really you know because
for a while the blog was was my only
means of kind of putting it out there do
you know what I mean yeah and then I
whether you know and I still would write
pieces but most of the pieces I wrote
after that worth
or specific things not so much for my
own blog if you don't have mania but
yeah it was just I think it was you know
just the shift in in how to best engage
an audience and then it really became
about you know you know Twitter and then
ultimately Instagram you know and then I
just can also got tired yeah what I
think like I'm trying to figure out
whether you know I I hesitate to use the
word like the mellowing you know because
I'm not sure that's accurate but on some
level either you have worked through
some of these anger issues and you have
a healthier relationship with your
emotional landscape or you just feel
like you're understood and hurt and so
you don't feel that you can like
sublimate those impulses that you still
have I think it's a little bit of both
I'd like the I hope there's been some
growth no I think there has been you
know you know I think kids will do that
to you and and look you know I think you
you success creates a certain amount of
personal security
you know and I mean so that you don't
you know the fear impulse that drives me
I think subsided as you know the work
spoke for itself right so I didn't feel
like I had you know failure chomping at
you know yeah you know oh yeah you're on
the third show that you've created you
have this amazing relationship with FX
and you know you know they have your
back even though you get into scruffs
with that I'm like you know I would hope
that you could like breathe a little bit
yeah I mean yes so there's definitely
feeling like you know I have the network
and by network non SI f X but the
network of people around me that
Know Who I am and can support that and
protect me and yeah so it's you know
it's it's definitely you know that has
you know changed my approach or yeah and
and you know it's also you know it's a
different it's a different landscape now
to man you know it's a much more you
know what you say and what you do you
know the the public perception is so
mercurial right now and and you know I
you know I would be foolish if I didn't
check myself you got a lot of weeds yeah
you know and or just you know know that
you know I've been lucky in the past
right if I use my you know early on when
I was you know sending out all those
crazy tweets about the Emmys right that
you know I was alone in my office
cracking myself up and then they were
all picked up and I got a call from my
wife saying what some are you going
insane that's happening people are
freaking out and I'm like what the [ __ ]
you talking about and then I just
realized oh my god they're like they're
all being picked up and people people
think I'm sitting there with a gun in my
mouth you know and I was like that was
when I realized oh tone can be construed
yeah so that was a little bit of a
tirade though yeah it was definitely a
tired but I was I was cracking myself up
but apparently no one else so you know I
have you know I definitely you know have
that historical awareness but you know
it's but yeah it's it's definitely it's
a different it's a different landscape
you know now it's a different landscape
in a lot of ways I mean yeah one one
false move and you're done you know it's
like you you know I think like there's a
climate of like you kind of have to you
know have to make sure that you're you
know really paying attention to how you
behave in a public forum yeah somebody
with your profile like you know
I would imagine that has to play on your
conscience a little bit in terms of how
you
yeah the gate the treacherous waters of
social media yeah and I think you know
it's also I think the landscape of
television has changed tremendously
since you know the shield and even in
and even you know Sons of Anarchy it's
like you know I know this this term gets
thrown around pretty casually but it
really is this amazing Golden Age like
there's this incredible content out
there and you know the quality of
programming in television is is just
it's unprecedented and as a storyteller
I would imagine that you know it's it's
exciting for you because it seems like
from somebody who's not in that world
that there's a lot of freedom to explore
storytelling in a longer format that can
breathe in this you know sort of binge
culture that we're now and no it's it's
it's really true I think you know it's
interesting it's I you know i I've
definitely rattled cages even at FX
along the way and but Landgraf always
kind of had here yeah he's kind of been
here yes but getting but you guys get
into it yeah you know you can only call
a guy a [ __ ] too many times before he he
has to sit you down and say you know
look I think he said like he said like
you know he pulls out the Jerry Maguire
let me help you help me oh yeah Kurt and
one
so there's definitely been you know some
of that along the way but I do I
I love John I consider him a friend and
but yeah it's you know the landscape now
is you know it's really it's really
changed you know and and now you know
like I just with the onset of minds and
and I just you know it made sense to
reapply deal at 20th and and then my
first look is that FX and you know like
a multi-year overall three-year deal
yeah and you know it's the first time I
had to you know in you know with you
know the potential of the Disney
ownership looming it's the first time I
had a sit-down before anything was
signed where you know I was given a
talking to and not so much you know I
mean clearly you know I've mellowed to a
certain extent and and but they know me
well yeah so this needs a whole other
deal yeah and it was and it wasn't so
much about don't be yourself as much as
don't be stupid you know and and at that
point I got it and and and I have
tremendous respect for Dana Walden who I
also consider a friend and and John
Landgraf and it was you know it was that
conversation but even you know even
though it was a supportive and we love
you kind of a meeting the fact that the
meeting still took place yeah suggest
people got together and said we need to
we need to we should probably get in
touch with Curtis right well look what
they're doing quite honestly and and and
you know and and and I don't blame them
right is they're you know they're doing
the due diligence of saying you know we
did our part in terms of letting this
artist know you know with the perhaps
new rules of engagement are right and so
that you know to a certain extent
they're protected if I you know go off
the rails but but it was also it's
interesting it's like like I said and it
was it was a very you know it was a very
sort of friendly and and supportive
conversation right but the fact that we
had to have that conversation really
suggests a shift in the paradigm you
know what I mean and and look I you know
everything kind of happens for I believe
everything sort of happens for a reason
and and that you know all the stuff
that's happening now in Hollywood and
and other industries you know had to
happen has to happen and and from it
what will shake loose I think is is
perhaps a more a safer and healthier
you know landscape but this is you know
this is the battle you know this is the
this is where people you know get bloody
and make mistakes and and this is the
the the time when you know things get
you know everything we're in that
in-between phase yeah we were shaking it
all up to see what it would it's
supposed to look there's you know
there's gonna have to be a lot of
casualties along the way but they'll see
our way clear of the old paradigm a new
paradigm I mean you I mean you worked
with Weinstein on southpaw right like it
was your experience with him you know I
never had a face to face with with
Harvey there was several email exchanges
and they were all very you know friendly
you know it was really about excuse me
it was really about when we were getting
beginning to promote the movie and and
asking me to you know do interviews and
and and things like that and you know
basically it was you know how much can I
get you to do for free kind of a thing
and and I you know and I and I got that
and I did as much as I could
you I couldn't travel and to to promote
but I you know I did I did a couple of
WGA things and but it was it was you
know he was very supportive of the movie
and look Antoine's a friend of mine and
we you know there was a lot of negotiate
you know there were rewrites on that
movie that that southpaw that you know
didn't work and so it was you know was
this sort of creative covert op that
would happen I would get home from sons
and I would sit down with him at like
from 10:00 till 2:00 in the morning
going through pages writing stuff for
the next day and and that basically I
think just became an outline because my
whole argument for arbitration when it
came down to who got credit because
there was like they brought in two or
three other writers my whole Harvard my
whole argument for arbitration was they
didn't follow any script so by default
did she go back to me and now we're and
you got so credit and it's and it's true
like there was whatever you know it was
it was the heart of basically the
original draft which is what Antoine
loved and wanted to make but as far as
actual words on the page it would be
like I'd be where's that but you know so
that and and it was like one of my met
and you know my agents and my lawyer
you know they've not had great
experience with arbitration and for
clients and they're like look don't you
know don't expect you know and it ended
up turning around being one of the
quickest arbitrations because my
argument was so simple and really there
was no documentation of any draft that
became the when TV it's called an as
broad in terms of what was actually said
right so they were like he's got a point
right and track it back to any anyone
else right so because the the movie was
mine and the original script and concept
was mine it just sort of by default went
back
sole credit yeah and which you know you
know was as far as they were concerned
was the first time anyone ever used that
time yeah that's what I be interested to
know whether anybody has used it since
but the the you know the story behind
that movie is pretty interesting I mean
originally this was an idea that you had
that you worked with Marshall Mathers
Eminem yeah he was gonna start he was
this was going to be his 8 mile
follow-up
yeah it really was it was they came to
me early on and and this is before
Antoine was around and you know
Marshalls producing team and and they
wanted to do a remake of the champ and I
was like don't do a remaking the champ
and and that's when I pitched let's
let's do like let's continue telling his
story through the analogy of boxing
right so the continuation of his life
you know so when proof was killed it's
sort of when you know the wife was
killed too is you literally taking the
paradigm of what happened to him
and then using that as you know sort of
the the story you know the story
paradigm right so and they loved that
idea and then we pitched it around and
it ended up with Stacy Snyder when she
was at DreamWorks and they loved the
idea and that point Marshall was am
bored and his team and and then we were
then we sat down and we're interviewing
or met with directors and you know an
Antoine came in and you know Antoine
obviously you know a lot of success with
training day and but had kind of lost
his way a little bit in terms of well
that's not fair to say in terms of
studio successes right we're still you
know looking for that groove
and and and I had worked with Antoine
previously on a project that I had
written for Warner's and that didn't go
but became friends with him and and he
came in to this pitch like living the
story like he grew up I think he grew up
in Philly and you know boxing kind of
saved his life so you know it was really
it became this sort of personal story
for him and that really impressed me and
Stacy and and and and all of Marshalls
people and we we locked him down and you
know and then as things happened
Marshall you know at that point I think
was clean and sober and I think
reevaluating whether or not he wanted to
get into a circumstance that you know
ate my own kind of [ __ ] him up you
know I think Curtis Hanson kind of put
him through the wringer and and I think
he you know this is just my speculation
but that he didn't know if he wanted a
risk new sobriety on that circumstance
again and and I kind of understood it
right so it went at the turnaround and
and then Harvey came around and like the
story and liked it for Jake and about a
year and a half later so that came back
around and I met with Jake and I think
I've told this story I know the story
you know there's teleca's it's good
because my relationship with Jake prior
to that was we had live we were living
in the Hills and Hollywood Hills and
someone moved into a house like across
from us so there's a big ravine right so
I don't know how many hundreds of yards
between our houses but somebody moved in
and and then for two nights in a row
somebody was out there like building
like banging hammers to like you know
midnight right and by the third night I
was like [ __ ] this guy so
so I stand out on the you know from the
from our at the end of our property
there as high up as I could and I'm
screaming you know hey you think maybe
you know you can you can [ __ ] chill
the [ __ ] home improvement it's it's
like you know 11 o'clock at night and
I'm screaming and all I hear is a pause
and okay okay right so then like three
or four days later there's a knock on my
door and open the door and it's Jake
yeah and he's like yeah I just want to
reach out we share I just moved into the
house and we share some mutual property
that we need to trim trees and I'm
sitting to him listen he's talking I
went were you the guy and he's like yeah
that was me I'm like of course it was
this relationship when the prospect of
him like starting this movie that you
wrote that you really wanted for eminem
comes up so but the second part of that
i think is just as like sort of
entertaining yeah so we sit down and and
so you know after that we we laughed and
you know then we were in contact with
him because we shared a property line
and we had done all this work thing it's
like rich white guy hollywood problem
yeah really really is like oh the trees
are too the trees are over growing and
my movie star neighbor like you know it
was it was it was that cry me a river
and and he was a lovely guy and and and
really you know i really you know i had
a good sense of humor about my rage so
and then over time he had actually moved
i think by the time this project came up
but that was our you know that was the
basis of our relationship and when
Harvey said that he really liked Jake
for this project like to me it was so
hard for me to wrap my head around
anybody but Marshall doing it because it
was written for him about him it was you
know and then it was based on his life
you know
for it granted you know an analogy and
and but so I couldn't like couldn't wrap
my brain around it and so I was you know
I was like as a scientist I don't get it
it's not gonna work and when I met Jake
you know he was a lovely guy and he had
a really it was interesting because he
had his perspective on who the character
was and in that meeting I found myself
creatively like tensing up like nuts not
who is you know and then and then I
don't know what happened I think it was
just like enough time had passed and I
perhaps wasn't so you know immediately
invested in every word which is probably
a good thing considering none of my
words ended up in it
but I think I was just I just something
happened and I and there was a shift and
I suddenly went oh that's what you think
it is right and I was able to realize of
course you know everyone is entitled to
their interpretation of it right and and
what I realized is that he was a really
smart cat right he wasn't like you know
he's a really smart guy and and and I
think really understood the character in
a way that perhaps I wasn't able to see
it right he was looking at it from a
different way and I think it's
ultimately why even though a lot changed
I realized because you know at that
point I was still you know 80% of my
year was always buried in the show that
I realized that Jake and Antoine knew
this character better than I did like
they understood and once Marshalls not
involved anymore you can unshackle
yourself from exactly the the
limitations of it having to be his story
exactly and and that was hard you know
creatively it was hard I'm very you know
look I'm very proprietary over my stuff
and and because I you know I'm not a
casual writer you know what I mean like
I spend a lot of time and energy and
investment in every word and
action that's in a script right so but I
realized that I you know that these two
men Jake and and Antoine at that point
really knew this movie better than I did
and I had to be willing to let that go
and and support it as best as I could
and I did with rewrites and you know and
most of my rewrites
I think were about you know guiding them
in the context of what the whole story
became you know and then I think a lot
of it just really became improvisational
once they understood that it was just
basically protecting the arc of the
peace because I think that's what
Antoine you know he's an amazing shooter
but I think what Antoine needs help with
sometimes is remembering you know how
each scene is layered into the overall
arc of a piece right and that's what I
think I was able to provide and and
ultimately let it become what it was
supposed to become you know yeah well I
mean I enjoyed it you know I don't know
what your perspective is on the finished
product but but I think you know first
of all you got to have huge balls to
even attempt a boxing movie because of
the history of boxing movies in and all
the tropes that are kind of built into
that like how do you say something
unique and do something compelling in
that genre when there's so many
outstanding examples seems like
everything's sort of been explored and
done yeah but I felt like it it it
merged kind of what you expect like the
best of what that genre has to offer
while also inverting it by throwing some
you know curveballs at you that like you
don't see coming
Plus like Jake was super ripped in that
movie I don't know how he got that fit
but it was insane well that's
interesting I you know I wasn't that
involved in in the actual production but
I was I did as much as I could
prior to in terms of rewrites and and
being available and and then as it was
being shot you know my late-night
rendezvous with with Antoine in terms of
revisions and stuff like that because it
was like a covert ops yeah piece you
know it's like I don't think people
understand like what an all-consuming
full-time job like being a showrunner is
like I can't believe that you had any
bandwidth whatsoever to do
anything outside of that well at that
point I was invested I really you know
look it's still my only you know feature
credit and and I really wanted to feel
like like the thought of abandoning it
at that point and felt wrong so I felt
like I wanted to support Antoine and
Jake and contribute what I could so yeah
it really became when I came home from
you know my day job putting as much
energy as I possibly could into that you
know and look it wasn't you know it was
like a you know it was a it was a quick
shoot right you know in terms of being
however many days 30 days maybe 40 days
and but no I'm you know I think Jake did
did a great job and and and look I think
they leaned into you know a lot of
tropes that I probably would have tried
to avoid but also you know I had to
trust that you know I guess there's a
there is an expectation being a boxing
movie for those mile markers you have to
reach you know what fans expect or
whatever but so you know I had mixed
feelings about it but ultimately you
know I felt like Antoine did a great job
I felt like Jake yeah I remember when I
met Jake he was doing Nightcrawler so he
was like that big you know it was really
he was lean and and and I thought you
know mmm middleweight mmm you know and
and then the next time I saw him was in
New York and maybe six weeks later and
he was a beast already six weeks in six
weeks but he's just one of those guy
like he's a natural athlete and he's
just one of those dudes that you know I
personally hate okay like drop in since
red and and and he was when I saw him he
was a beast and and you know it is a
natural athlete so I think he was you
know had moved along at a rate faster
than I forget
Terry was his name I forget Terry's last
name who was training him and you know I
think even Terry was
of stunned at his level of how quickly
you know and it's just who he is you
know and and you know I think he created
a really interesting character it was he
was kind of you know barbaric you know
and in a way that I had never seen him
before so I really admired his
performance you know and it was
beautiful I loved the way Antoine shot
it so you know I was able to sort of why
I remember I watched it I was in I was
in London doing bastard at the time and
ended up going the Soho House and in
Soho went and went to their private
screening room and watched it with I
think Katie and just Saren Jackson at
the time and we just you know had a
private screening and you know
ultimately you know came out of that
feeling like okay I'm glad my name's on
it you know I didn't write much of it my
name is such a weird thing all right
like you're this I mean you know like
the average person would look at that
and just assume you wrote every word in
that movie and that's not how it works
and I think it's it speaks to kind of a
broader issue that I want to get into
you with you which is like how do you
you know navigate being a creative
person being an artist you know being
somebody who's passionate about the work
that they do in a construct in which
it's a team sport really and you know I
know you well enough to know that like
you're a guy who likes to lock yourself
in a room and like do your thing and you
know people if you can avoid people
you're gonna avoid people you know and
it's so funny that the universe has
thrown you you know this life in which
not only do you have to collaborate with
people like you have to be like the
general and the soldier like you you
have to be the practitioner and the
architect of everything that you do so
I can't imagine very many other jobs
where you you have to be more in meshed
with people and then what you do so it's
like I you know I I would imagine there
was a learning curve with that like and
I think it also you know kind of an
celerity of that is how do you maintain
the
you know what you're trying to
accomplish while also allowing that
space to you know be in gratitude and in
surrender and like empower all these
people that are talented in their own
right to be expressive no you know I
it's it's interesting that I you know I
was never you know I'm a late bloomer
right like I didn't figure [ __ ] out till
you know I was in my early 40s right I
mean some of it was going back to grad
school you mean a brother you know and I
you know I went back to grad school in
my early 30s and I was gonna teach and
direct theater and and it was in grad
school I started writing and you know
that sort of then dictated my path so
there was this really this very long
circuitous path that led me to what I'm
doing and I have you know obviously a
lot of gratitude for that but you know
prior to that anything I had written
like the concept of draft never entered
my mind right like I would produce
something and if you didn't you know
think it was you know the most potent
and brilliant thing you would have ever
written you'd ever read then clearly it
was a piece of [ __ ] so you know the
binary yeah so the fact that I my career
became something that has to embrace the
concept of draft is you know is
definitely you know in a bigger picture
you know
the lesson that I had to learn right
because I was then to be successful I
had to be willing to let people share an
opinion about what was wrong with
something I was doing and and take it to
heart tried to figure out what was
useful you know what I could throw away
and what how to apply what they said to
make something better and clearly there
was a learning curve doing that but that
you know that perhaps was the biggest
hurdle and and I was able to get through
a lot of that in just trying to write
features so that by the time I got to
the shield you know then I didn't have a
choice right because I would write
drafts and I would get notes from my
showrunner and from other writers and
you know I'm a push back for stuff I
believed in but ultimately I couldn't
say [ __ ] you write it yourself if you
were like a senior at junior status here
juniors that you have such rights each
season wanna battle so I was you know
you start out at the bottom and but it
was interesting I was and I always tell
this story my my buddy Scott Rosenbaum
was also the other staff writer on that
show and I had never written in TV
before I never pursued TV and and I like
TV and and my agents were like you know
you should write some specs and and you
know so I got this gig after you know a
couple seasons of trying to pursue TV
work well you wrote you wrote like a
like a crazy spec script of Ally McBeal
spec script yeah West wing's but hey I
wrote a crazy Ally McBeal like you know
that's so funny you remember that like
an S&M Ally McBeal your voice in that in
that framework and and then a like a
West Wing where you know eight-year-old
version
unfortunately somewhat prescient in
terms of like what ultimately happened
but are you trying to like it like adopt
some kind of sorkin ask like meter when
you write dialogue in that or you isn't
being yourself I couldn't you know what
I tried to do in terms of the show was
the rhythm right because it had a fast
rhythm I don't you know I think it's
impossible to it's like trying to
imitate Mamet right it's an it's really
difficult to to try to mirror or ape
that rhythm you know but I did sort of
understand the dynamic of who the
characters were and what the
relationships were but that that West
Wing was what got me the job on the
shield because at that point that's what
you did to get a job
you wrote a spec of a successful show
and you know so but the interesting
thing is I started that job and I had
never written on a TV show
nor did I luckily didn't really know the
rules right like I got the show and I
there was a contract that was for seven
years right and and I just thought like
oh okay so you know if the show
continues I you know like I'll keep
working what I didn't know is that you
know each season your your option had to
be picked up right and a lot of times if
you go into a gig if you have two staff
writers a lot of times you know only one
of them makes the jump so my buddy Scott
Rosenbaum had written on TV shows before
and was aware of that dynamic so I
remember showing up and I just
remembered god this guy's so [ __ ]
competitive man he's gonna bury ya and
and so and I was just I was sort of
taken back by it and then of course I
realized you know how competitive I was
myself right so then it but it wasn't
about the job it was about well [ __ ]
this you know just became about yeah you
know the idea and and it wasn't until
like really as the season was winding
down that I became aware that my option
had to be picked up and I and as as as a
big of a shock that was in terms of what
didn't anybody tell me that I realized
well it's a blessing that nobody told me
that because had I known that it may
have shifted my dynamic into a much more
sort of defensive were judging
everything I was saying or looking at
all my relationships differently and the
ego yeah and I was able just to sort of
be my self and and let my you know my
warped sense of storytelling kind of
flourish you know and and really found
my voice on that on that show you know
well I think I want to explore kind of
like you know your experience on the
shield and how that led to suns and
everything that's happened since but I
think I think we should let's step it
back because I want to you know I want
to know I want to understand like how
this how this Kurt Sutter
I came to be right like it there's an
interesting kind of backstory here that
is the engine behind all of this growing
up in New Jersey right right
you want the sad fat kid story okay no
not really but I do like first of all
like 400 pounds like in high school it's
super hard for me to see that yeah you
know grew up in in like suburb Jersey
raw town I grew up in town called Clark
I usually say Rahway because I lived
like you know five blocks from the Royal
way border
and people knew wrong way because of the
prison and scared straighter so it was
just easier and it sounded more
yeah they got IMDB it says like you know
corrupt in the shadow of the Raleigh
he's like it sounds so melodramatic I
know yeah I was so proud of that but you
know I was already marketing myself you
know my first year on the show but um so
you know grew up in really sort of you
know middle-class suburbia and and you
know was you know I in hindsight I look
at it now and realize it's you know it
was the youthful manifestation of my
isms you know of my alcoholism and and
my my holes so to speak but I you know
from an early age you know it was just
this uber sensitive dude and and I
didn't nobody was mixing me cocktails
and you know three four and five and it
became you know food really became my
you know an aesthetic and you know and
so my weight gain was sort of
proportional to life right so the more
[Music]
responsibility life demanded of me the
bigger I got to the point where you know
I was you know I say over 400 pounds cuz
the scale didn't go past
mmm-hmm when I was 19 you know so and I
lost some weight in high school I
dropped like 60 pounds
my mom god bless her you know sent me to
like one of the diet clubs and dropped
some weight but then quickly put that
back on and and and another 50 and you
know then I I went to college went to
Rutgers and you know my first year all I
did was party and you know put on
another 50 pounds of beer weight right
and of course didn't go to class so I
ended up dropping out of Rutgers and
going to junior college but I don't know
I there was some thing that happened I
think I just and I you know I tell this
as a in a humorous way because it's
funny but it's really ultimately I think
it's probably the truth which was you
know I realized that 400 pounds I wasn't
gonna get laid right and and not because
women you know didn't like me it's
because you know they could die so like
to get up to that size I mean my you
know the impression that I got from kind
of like you know looking into the
background of your story is you know
baby boomer parents you know dad kind of
is that emotionally detached dude you
know we all know that guy yep
you know mom you know mom begins to deal
with that by drinking a little bit of
herself and so then that becomes an
emotional removal for you right it's
like all right where are you gonna turn
now yeah right so sorry it's like food
and then it's no surprise that it's
that's booze what your ballooning up and
if that when does like I mean the first
thing that kind of comes in in terms of
like your salvation is like this
interest in acting right friend what
writing doesn't come till much later
yeah I think it was um yeah I
and like I said I I think when I you
know there was a certain amount of
denial one has when they're younger
right and then I think I just hit the
wall at nineteen where I realized you
know is it you know this it didn't you
know like I always described you know
it's like I I was like the you know I
was like I had the the personality of
James Dean in the body of Paul Prudhomme
right like it just didn't [ __ ] work
right you know yeah and so I get super
handsome dude like stuck in this other
guy's body so I just you know and then
you know I you know I'm really on my own
you know sort of flip the switch and and
of course you know there's a healthy
component to it but there's also an
unhealthy component to it in terms of
you know that's when I really started
relying on alcohol to take the edge off
instead of food you know and and you
know I look at my alcoholism and my drug
addiction and my food addiction as being
so amesh t' in my 20s it's hard to even
pull them apart right because when I
wasn't doing one I was doing the other
right right well it's all the same thing
you have this you have this like you
know discontented miss this sense of
like not wanting to feel the way that
you feel and they're gonna reach for
whatever's in front of you yeah it
really is indiscriminantly yeah and you
know so I you know I dropped you know
and look I was at an age where and you
know the interesting thing is and as
heavy as I was I was always like an
athletic kid like I played baseball I
love basketball you know so I was the
kid playing full court basketball at 400
pounds you know you know it's amazing I
have like you know knees at this point
but so like the exercise component was
was easy for me so when I you know made
the decision to drop weight I you know
exercise became a big tool and then
ultimate
you know you you know you abused that
too right and but you know so I I got
down to you know I dropped like 180
pounds 190 or 190 pounds and in you know
like nine months Wow so just by just
being like a beast on the Stairmaster or
whatever in the treadmill like you know
I mean it's restrictive you know like
cocaine and positive matter like there
was you know cocaine ultimately became
my maintenance tool mm-hmm you know what
I mean but initially it was really you
know it became this like how little can
I eat and still sort of do what I need
to do right yeah and I don't like a
control thing absolutely yeah it's it's
it was you know it was a form of you
know anorexia and then ultimately
exercising became the bulimic part of
that right so you know look I it
happened the way it happened and it had
to to a certain extent and and it wasn't
necessarily the healthiest process but
you know I got away with it because I
was young right so and I you know but I
always describe it as you know having my
body size and doubling my insanity
because I was now in the body of a
normal looking dude but I still had this
head that was you know that whole skill
set was built on you know you know being
400 pounds and just disconnected and and
living you know in in a great deal of
fantasy right so you know that really
became the the struggle in my 20s you
know like maintaining the weight I would
sort of you know I've sort of maintained
anywhere between like you know 180 and
220 I was always sort of somewhere in
that you know but it was all you know it
all became about binge and purge and you
know all the things that all the
different ways the
ISM manifests you know what I mean and
and still very much into not you know I
wasn't a big drug guy a lot you know
cocaine was so prevalent in the 80s in
New York where I was working it was just
part of the party circuit you know but
it was it was mostly alcohol and you
know and that became you know you know
my my coping mechanism for you know
until I'll you know like all of us it
stops working
yeah it's not worried but it seems that
you didn't have it's not like you had
some crazy flame out like it just sort
of ran its course and you're like I can
do this anymore
what was the bottom um I think what
happened was I look like I had you know
my mom was alcoholic and I sort of had
the blueprint you know I saw what my
genetic predisposition was and and I'm a
guy who you know I kind of have to ride
it ride it out until it's completely
beat up and done and trained you know
even to this day like working with dry
defects of character right I got a you
know I got to try it every which way to
make sure it really is a defect before
before I'm willing to go okay it doesn't
work right so it was that kind of thing
and I and I think I I remember you know
I talked to I think was my friend Nicole
who ultimately became my agent you know
talking to her about it and we both had
our stuff and and you know and I would I
would like sort of wine and in her ear
and and she you know pointed out that
most people who aren't alcoholic
you know don't struggle with the the
complexities and the the angst of
whether or not they're alcoholic
and I just was like that was so obvious
and yet such a brand-new concept to me I
was like oh and then I just became
willing and I and at that point I had
moved back to New York I was studying
with my mentor
Catherine Caitlyn to teach and direct
theatre and and I was just I you know I
was willing to let it go and and then of
course you know you realize your bottom
is not quite as high as you think it is
right and and that you know that'll be
25 years ago amazing you just moderately
or something you came in and that was
yeah like I had tried to get sober on my
own you know like I was dry for nine
months you know and and and hadn't drank
and you know and then what happens is
you pick up again and it's not a slow
build again you sort of pick up again
and it's within weeks you're right back
where you were usually worse right so
you know it was so I mean I was so aware
of what I was doing and and I just you
know I became you know exhausted by my
own process of trying to figure out you
know how to get well then I was just
like all right I'll try it this way
intellectualizing and yeah for every
other way of being able to continue to
do what you do but not feel the way
exactly
yeah well that's amazing I mean that's
it's not that's not the usual story you
know with most people it's it's less of
a you know of a clean break like that or
you know a linear path but now looking
at it like knowing that there's the food
aspect of it and then there's a drugs
and alcohol part of it like
how do you manage like sort of recovery
across those two different things
because the solution is the same and yet
it's also a little bit more complicated
than that you know the drug into drugs
and alcohol of it you know is you know
is is a clean break right so not that it
was easy you know but but you know they
in the food program or you know
overhears Anonymous they talk about you
know that if if the disease is the tiger
you know when you're sober you can put
the tiger in the cage but with food you
have to take that tiger out and walk it
three times a day right so you know that
has always been my you know that to this
day is the thing that you know I still
struggle with right is you know is the
main you know is maintaining that level
of you know abstinence and and and and
you know you know what is you know
what's the normalcy in that process you
know you know because I'm you know and I
don't that's not a program I work
anymore and whether or not that's a good
thing or a bad thing I don't know but
you know it's still it still can kick my
ass on any given day right but you know
it's you know the the other program is
the one that sort of you know is mine my
daily tool for living you know what I
mean yeah but you know here's the I
guess the best way to describe it is
like I'm so clear with drugs and alcohol
there's no you know there's no other
route but sobriety right I'm always
looking for another route in terms of
food and but you know like I'm always
looking for the shortcut you know what
does it look like now I mean we've
talked a little
about like the plant-based stuff with
you right right I don't know where
you're at with it now and how that looks
but I'm you know I am very obviously
look I'm health-conscious and and and I
[Music]
you know I love you know working out and
and and weight training has always been
part of my emotional recovery you know
and I still do that anywhere from three
to five times a week
right on so exercise and it's still you
know really how I you know keep that
beast at bay and right now in terms of
my food plan it's strictly I would say
pescetarian you know what I mean I do
eat you know I do eat fish but but
pretty much everything else is I tried
to like I don't do about it's been
almost a year
giving up dairy and wheat you know yeah
I you know ridiculous ridiculous amounts
of Ezekiel you know and and I just you
know I feel better you know when I'm
when I'm in that groove right and I'm a
you know I'm a vitamin [ __ ] you know I
you know I I but you know they I you
know there's debate about the
effectiveness of that but you know I
take vitamins three times a day and and
I'm very aware of you know all my
nutritional levels you know like I do
blood work every two months with my god
you know say like I like I'm here's what
I here's the good thing about where I'm
at with it all now I no longer like it's
so easy for me to live in the vague you
know this sort of like you know and I
don't do that anymore meaning like I'm
you know I'm aware
of where I'm at pretty much even even
the stuff I don't like I stay aware of
you know what I mean right you're not in
denial like that you have some you know
where your blood pressure is at your
cholesterol and all that kind of [ __ ]
like you're staring it in the face but
that's it
it's a as somebody who struggled with
your relationship with food and having a
kind of a healthy you know handshake
with it
it's a tricky tightrope walk because if
you get too into that kind of stuff then
you're back into like obsession yes you
know yeah I don't know I'll tell you
this story and I don't I think you might
know this or maybe not but you know I
for the longest time if I was not
plant-based I was pescetarian right and
I worked out four to five times a week
you know I you know I've always you know
I'm always obsessing about my weight but
I'm you know I'm I was in a fairly
healthy range and and my blood
pressure's always been on the high side
because it's hereditary right my dad had
high blood my dad stroked and a when he
was in his 50s right so it's something
I'm just aware of and I've never found
like I was on different medications and
I just didn't like them so I avoided
that you know I just tried to like do it
with diet and but my MD was you know she
was you know like it was getting to the
point where she was worried right so she
I did my routine checkup and you know
got on the treadmill and did the EKG and
and and she saw something on the EKG
that she knew was like nothing but used
it as an excuse to sent me to a
cardiologist right and said you should
go see the cardiologist and and it was
basically so that the cardiologist would
scare me into taking blood pressure meds
right she was like teaming up on me
right you know what I mean like to get
like you know so I go to the
cardiologist and with Kayden I did the
big the two big you know the test and
you're in the the road of thing and they
do the calcium yeah all the whole whole
day
right and I was like literally or like
just give me every [ __ ] test you have
right so we can see that everything's
fine I didn't get the [ __ ] out here and
so we get into the office right and
we're sitting down with my cardiologist
who now is like you know my best friend
and he looks really worried he's like um
can you I had something come up can you
guys come back after lunch and once you
go cross street grab lunch and really go
okay then we're lunch were like wow when
it would happen like he looked really
worried like you know and completely
clueless that when we get back that who
he was worried about was me and that a
major order in my heart was like 90%
clogged
right and had led lower yeah yeah and
and he had nothing to do with diet
it was completely hereditary and
probably started happening 15 20 years
ago the breakdown at all right yeah this
it's over time this is exactly what
happening Kevin Smith yes yes and so we
go back to his office and he shows me
the pictures right and I'm just like I'm
like no I'm like it's like who are you
talking about you know I'm the guy that
you know I work out six days a week um
you know I eat you know and so I went
and you know they do
I had a stent put in right and but my
reaction to that and this is a little
you know this is you know what kind of
cloth I'm cut from right my reaction to
that was [ __ ] this right and that's when
I started smoking that's when I started
eating meat my reaction to it was well
if this if if doing all this has nothing
to do with the quality of life in my
health what the [ __ ] is a point yeah
forget it forget it and it's so
interesting and I started smoking and
you know so the whole time
doing bastard in the UK you know I got
up til the pack and a half a day I knew
that you were smoking yeah and I was
like what are you doing like maybe he's
just stressed out I did not know that he
ought to stand put in yeah but that was
my response to it right not like oh my
god you cuz in your mind you're like
I've been a good boy exactly and this is
what I get right so thank you I can't I
can't be any healthier than I already am
so [ __ ] it right but those plaques you
know started when you were 7 years old
oh yes like it's a lifetime of building
up exactly exactly but the truth is you
can and I'm sure your cardiologist has
told you this like you can reverse that
stuff yes yes and thank God you had a
stent put in and you didn't have like a
massive coronary nothing there were it
was asymptomatic you know until it's not
yeah you know and so it was so surreal
and that was you know that's the kind of
cloth I'm cut from her that's how I
dealt with it yeah I'm not surprised
no I know you know it's like pushing
back on everything yeah I mean like you
at times your own worst enemy
yeah absolutely yeah and and the whole
time I'm doing it completely aware on
some level mm-hmm what was happen so so
yeah and you know and then and then of
course you know I try to quit and I'm
like oh this is what they mean when you
know so uh and and it's not like I you
know started smoking and dropped 50
pounds
you know like none of that happened but
you know the whole time I was in London
I was smoking and then I came back and
you know it took me about six months to
ultimately let it go and and then I did
and then you know my lifestyle shifted
and got back to you know what I knew was
not just the way to live is how I lived
you know and which is you know where I'm
sort of at now right but there was a two
and a half year period where I was like
what's the point
and
and and I don't recommend that to anyone
yeah not a good idea I'm glad you came
back from that though man you know
you're a good dude we want you to stick
around you know it's so weird because
it's like I never had any doubt that
that's how I feel it's not like I
thought that's who I am now like that's
that it's that it's that distinction
between like intellectually you know you
have total awareness of what you're
doing and you know it's not good for you
and yet what is that thing that's
compelling you to like walk down that
dark alley mm-hmm yeah it is it's that
you know and who you're you know it's
that you know [ __ ] you but the only
person you're saying [ __ ] you do it sir
like who you who you defies this person
yeah
so you know and God you know my in my
wife Kate was you know like she saw all
this happening and you know and you know
we were we had our own stuff going on at
the time and so it was just this you
know it was this sort of you know
bizarro Kurt for like two years you know
and I mean and and still you know
navigating around some of that but but
as far as you know health stuff it's you
know it's really been you know it's been
a little bit over a year and and and
that's where you know the conversation
we first had when I when I saw you today
was about weight and you know like I
knew when I was like quitting that I was
going to pack on weight and that's to
know what I sort of changed things up in
terms of my workout and and and if I was
gonna put on weight at least I wanted to
put it on in the right place and muscle
yeah and change up the beard geography a
little bit yeah yeah that was actually
that was actually for some acting I okay
you know yeah cool so let's work up to
that I mean all right so so you kind of
bail on Rutgers you go to New York City
you're studying Meisner you're doing
like you know off-broadway theater right
stuff like that yes bad awful and then
like you moved to LA but then you
go to grad school in in northern
Illinois like you know what's what's
going on like you kid when did you first
come out to LA I first came out to LA in
the mid 80s late 80s as an actor you
know and I'm pursued acting out here and
and and that's sort of when like I
didn't get sober but I knew you know I
had started going to a a at that point
and and I was aware of you know what
some of my demons were like I was I was
things were becoming you know these
things were becoming sort of getting
into focus and and I came out here I
came out here at an to LA at an odd time
it was the first writers strike back in
the 80s and it was just in like the
really bad time there's nothing and then
I talked to you know my mentor studying
in New York was this woman Catherine
Gately and and you know and so I
ultimately went back to New York to
study with her to teach right because I
thought like this is really what I love
to do and if I can't do it as an actor
you know this was a technique that
really spoke to me that I understood on
a really sort of visceral level and
perhaps you know I can I can teach it
and and then direct theater and that was
sort of the plan coming back to New York
in the early 90s and then you know I was
with Catherine and and then Catherine
was offered a sort of master teaching
position at Northern Illinois University
about a half hour outside of Chicago and
and she you know really sort of took me
under her wing and took me along as and
so I went out there as a student you
know but really with the focus of
learning the tech you know and it's the
technique I had studied with her right
so it was about you know taking the
technique again really looking at it
through the eyes of being a teacher or a
director
and you know and I did that for I was
it's a three year program and I was in
DeKalb Illinois for two years and then
you know the rest of it I did pretty
much through um through independent
studies alright and so was the dream
then that you would go into academia or
the yes theater director the dream then
was like oh this is you know a teacher
I'm gonna get into academia not
realizing that first of all the arts
budgets in across the board in all
schools were shrinking and being a white
male was was not you know high on the
you know the registry in terms of who
was being hired and you know and really
became aware that if I wanted to do that
most likely it would be like you know
some Community College out you know
right grizzly point you know where else
would you feel like you couldn't go back
to New York and and or LA and like take
a stab at the acting thing don't like
did you get your ass handed to you or do
you just feel like you were there at the
wrong time like what was your mindset
then I think at that point I really you
know I loved acting but I think I really
um you know I was really focused on you
know teaching and directing like I it's
not that I didn't like acting and I and
obviously I did a lot of it when I was
in grad school right it's part of the
program and but it really was you know
wanting to you know basically you know
how do I make a career out of the arts
that are the thing that I love right and
felt like you know as much as I loved
acting being an actor was to you know my
practical you know pragmatic brain
couldn't sit with you know or couldn't
trust that my control like a control and
that I could make a living out of that
and yet so if there was something you
know I could do that
sort of
tapped into that love but was a little
bit more secure that made sense yeah so
that was a little bit of dad talking to
you in the back your head on that Oh a
lot of yeah I mean what was there like
what was their perspective on on you
like pursuing a career in the arts I
think they think they realized that it's
it's what I wanted to do they were very
supportive of me going back and getting
my degree you know they always were but
something I can understand yeah you know
and understood like oh okay here's a you
know it was much it was pragmatic it
wasn't quite as elusive as trying to be
you know a TV star or and you know what
I mean and so they were supportive of it
and and but you know it took a while for
them to to get there yeah I'm in here
and but then you know what ended up
happening is I come out of that
circumstance and it was a great
experience like some of you know really
you know some of the most satisfying
years of my life in terms of the art
right and and really immersing myself in
a way that I was never able to do in New
York when I was you know trying to
survive and being an actor right
you know exposed to such great dramatic
literature in a way I'd never been
exposed to before and just really kind
of opened up my mind and exposed me to
you know some really some really great
writers and and playwrights who were
your guys
I like the surreal you know the the
Surrealists
you know like janae and Epson and you
know all those crazy Russians you know
the the it was sort of like the ones
that spoke to me you know as well you
know I'm a huge Eugene O'Neill fan you
know
so but those you know the the the really
damaged ones that's surprising
and you know it's like I love those I
love those the Russians you know like
checkup where you know I'm face value
you can read it and be like oh my god
and then realize boy man this is a
comedy have to go back and like you know
but so you know for me it was you know
just such an amazing experience but then
ultimately I went back I had met my
first wife at that point and went back
to LA and the plan was maybe two to
teach privately right because I realized
you know I just didn't have the I just
didn't want to be like in some community
college and anywhere new USA he read and
I thought well maybe I you know I had a
friend out here who or a colleague who
was had her own studio and maybe I could
you know you set up a shingle and sort
of had that be who you know how to do
this I started writing in grad school a
little bit and and then through a series
of events began writing out here and and
at some point that really pulled focus
you know it's weird that that you had to
kind of go through everything you know
all these other disciplines around the
world of writing more you kind of hit
that bullseye for yourself yeah it
really is and I and it's interesting
because I it was a very circuitous you
know but what I realize is that
everything I did up to that not just
life experience but you know
academically and training wise really
created a unique set of tools that gave
me what ultimately became my voice and
that any other way it probably wouldn't
have happened now it's hard to you know
and the only way that can happen is to
let it happen and then look at it in
hindsight writers but you know that
became really clear to me that yeah it
took me a long time to get here and you
know when I first got my first gig on
the shield I was 10 years older than
everybody you know and you know but at
that point I you know my trajectory
happened fairly quickly and it's almost
like I you know it's like all that stuff
was sort of just lying and wait yeah and
it got plugged into like just the sort
of ultimate project for you to sink your
teeth like it couldn't have been more
kind of creative creatively aligned yes
you know with where your instincts we're
coming right I mean were you aware of
that and the time or you're just you're
probably still trying to figure out what
your voice is yeah you know it's
interesting like your first gig it was
it wasn't it was so crazy and I just
remember I remember at my my wedding to
Kate that Sean said a few words are and
we had it at our house and at the time
it was fearless and and and I always
remember the Shan Shan being the Korea
Sean Ryan who is a creator and who hired
me and at that point I think we were in
like this second or third or the third
or fourth season we were you know into
it and you know Sean described me as
like everyone else because the world was
so sort of dark and you know you know
you had to go to those places you don't
necessarily like to go to that everybody
else sort of you know took off a shoe
and dip their toe in and that I
basically stripped down naked and dive
in headfirst right which which I you
know which is kind of true right
and because it was it was familiar water
for me
right it was that sort of offbeat kind
of dark looking at the world through you
know a lens that you're not supposed to
look through right and and it really was
you know it was so fortuitous that that
was my first show and not like you know
and not that this isn't you know and
like network TV didn't have great shows
but if I had you know if I wasn't
allowed to like be who I was and someone
tried to wrangle me through a different
filter you know my career would probably
be much different right I mean what if
what if you ended up writing for Ally
McBeal like that I mean it's like you
know the fact that you ended up on the
shield I mean so it's it's like almost
universally divine because and the
timing is so important as well I think
it's hard for people to understand like
this is before break bad this is before
like you know this whole like era of the
antihero hadn't real I mean The Sopranos
I guess you know Tony Soprano the hero
but like that fully fleshed out like arc
over many seasons of this you know
really palpable visceral antihero hadn't
occurred yet and Vic Mackey really like
brought that to life and your sir
credited with writing like a lot of the
gnarliest you know scenes that transpire
that series yeah I you know Shawn was
such a great mentor and and really you
know you know some you know at the time
I'm brand-new right so I'm being driven
you know creatively you know inspired
but you know personally and emotionally
I'm terrified right because it's like
it's the first time I've had anything
real and I'm so afraid that it's going
to go away you know I'm I'm you know I'm
a I'm a mousetrap right ready to spring
you know so I was really bullish and and
you know incredibly proprietary over you
know what I wanted to do and and you
know and a lot of showrunners I think
would have you
been intimidated by that and and Shawn
was just a smart guy and in and in
intuitive enough to sort of you know
rein me in when I needed to be reined in
but for the most part just sort of put
up the bumpers that took me in the right
direction and and really you know it's
why I feel I have a lot of you know I
stayed on that show till the end right
and seven seven seasons right yeah and I
really feel like you know I was able to
contribute at least tonally to the show
do you know what I mean you know
ultimately it's Shawn's vision in terms
of story but that you know I felt like I
was really able to find my voice
you know within the confines of that of
that world in that character and you
know and a lot of people wouldn't
allowed me to do that yeah or would have
been intimidated by that and tried to
shut me down or be threatened by it and
Shawn you know was just you know really
smart enough and you know and and enough
of a mentor to sort of nurture it and
you know set me on fire at the right
times do you know what I mean yeah and
maybe have a more than a few
conversations behind closed doors with
other people perhaps you know try to
make it you know how does it work like
I'm always amazed when I watch you know
a program of that caliber and knowing a
little bit about how production works
it's just amazing that anything good
ever gets made you know when you see
something that's really good and knowing
like the time constraints and the
pressures and like all these
personalities that have to come together
and conspire to like create something
right you know I'm just I'm baffled by
it and I'm amazed and I'm always
wondering like how does a righty how
does a writers room work like you're in
I just have this vision of like a bunch
of people sitting around a conference
room table like eating Chinese food it's
read in the morning and getting
arguments some of it I think comedy
works very different than then drama you
know I think there's a lot of that
happens in comedy it's a lot you know
there's a lot more personalities in the
room because you're doing story but
you're also telling jokes right so
you're you're servicing you know two
masters for drama you know you know you
anywhere from five to seven writers
usually and you have one writer that
runs the room and and the showrunner you
know the way I work is and in and you
know really from sons on you know I'll
have one writer that kind of runs the
room for me right and we'll you know
sort of steer steer story in a certain
direction then I'll come in and I'll
weigh in on you know what works what
doesn't work what we need and you know
and plug in you know at different points
of the day and but prior to that you
there must be some sort of you know
meeting of the minds where everyone gets
together and you kind of have to break
the arc of the season right like okay
this is these are the things are gonna
transpire over these 10 or 13 hours yeah
I mean the way I work is you know
they'll be you know I'll have a general
arc that like for Mayans right there's
for this first season there's a you know
there's a sort of a broad arc that I
want a service in terms of the show like
where it starts and kind of where I want
our hero to or antihero to land and at
the end of that at the end of that if
you could imagine seven years of that
show you know I had a bigger arc for
Suns that wasn't necessarily beat for
beat of where the show was going but a
great but a sense of you know broad
strokes where I wanted it to go like I
knew I wanted Jax to be President and
now and I have some of that for mines
but perhaps not quite as much and I
think that's a good thing because what I
learned on Sung's is that you know I'd
have these sort of general arcs or these
concepts for each season and then I
learned that the looser I held on to
them the better the season was right so
I used them really as catalysts right
and and mile markers but then I don't if
the story is going in a different
direction I don't try to bend it to like
a pre-existing idea if it's going in a
different direction you know and that's
really you know the way the way I'll
work so you know for the mines I'll I go
in with the writers and I sort of pitch
out generally where I want it to land
you know and and then we'll have a sense
of alright
you know maybe and by Episode four I
want this to happen and then by episodes
well we're doing on the pilot plus nine
right where that you know so episode
four and then by episode eight and then
you know so by the end where we're at
this place right but it's really it's
you know it's sort of broad and and then
sometimes I'll break out all aboard with
episodes and sort of where I want some
of those bigger moments to happen and
and then you know I let you know we'll
come up each episode you have you know
an a story a main story and then usually
there's a something that's more
character driven that's a B story
sometimes even a see story like a little
runner that's two or three beats and and
then you know but that that sort of
moves you forward towards some of those
mile markers I know but I learned that
you know the more I more open I am to it
going someplace else you know as long as
I don't lose the vision of the show you
know the better the show is right rather
than being rigid on some idea that you
had previously yeah where it's naturally
flow yeah and and just like you know the
like a great character beat right or a a
narrative beat that's really you know
that speaks to the characters in the
world you know that may send the
trajectory going in a different
direction and you know not that you
can't ultimately land where you want to
land but you may have two or three
points along the way and rather than
bending it to try to hit those you find
you know you you trust that if you
continue to do what you're doing
you'll feel you know you'll find what
you're supposed to pass through to get
to that point you know yeah interesting
you you had said earlier you know by
virtue of this grad school experience
that that you've learned that you know
you've learned these tools for how to
tell stories don't know how to be its
storyteller so like what are those tools
like what is your perspective on how you
know what makes you the storyteller that
you are one of the guiding principles
about um that's a great question I think
you know for me in in grad school it was
being exposed to you know and it's it's
it's not it's nothing that you can then
like kind of rip out and go oh I'm gonna
use that knowledge here right Kurt
Sutter's five tips but I think what I
what I learned was here's here's where
where my you know my narrative and and
littered and my exposed exposure to you
know to dramatic literature classic
dramatic literature you know the poetic
realists were obviously my favorite
right where that knowledge and and then
my acting sort of kind of worked hand in
hand is that you know I always had a
really good sense for
[ __ ] moments right like if I was it
which made me a pretty good director and
a pretty good teacher right is that I
could usually know when actors were not
connected or their the moment didn't
feel real and you know so what I was
able when I realized I was able to do is
take that skill and apply it to how I
write dialogue so that I you know you
know it's why I'm not a showrunner that
gives actors freedom with language like
the line no improvising on your side
yeah you know the words on the page of
the words I want to hear and if they
don't work we'll figure it out together
but like I spend a lot of time and
energy in putting the right words in the
in the characters mouths right and so I
realized that ultimately that skill was
very translatable to writing you know
like I can hear you know oh when I write
you know the magic for me is you know be
alone in my office and you know I'll
hear that conversation you know and I'll
you know I'll be in it and I'll feel it
and you know you know be weeping at the
parts where those characters are weeping
or angry like I can I can take the
emotional journey of the characters yeah
you're like an emotional cipher yeah and
I think that's what allows me to at the
very least write authentic dialogue you
know and and then you know and then I
have to be collaborative in terms of
letting my director have an
interpretation of that and having the
actor have their interpretation but
ultimately as long as those moments are
you know steer the story in the right
direction then you know I'm doing my job
I don't know forget what your question
was but the follow-up to that would
really be you know what is what is your
like practice of writing like are you
dude you have like a routine you have
like a methodology for how you approach
these things are you a late-night guy
it's it's like if I had 10 days to write
a script or rewrite a script like I'll
get my register
and you know I wish I had the ability to
do this and and I'm a you know this is a
in fact this weekend I get my first
draft from you know I wrote the first
episode which is done and and I'm
getting the next episode that to other
writers have written and you know for
the most part I always sort of do a page
one rewrite right and it's not has
nothing to do with the writers inability
to understand or interpret the story
it's just I you know I kind of have to
hear the voices in my head you know what
I mean so which is really my process you
know what I mean so you're actually
acting it out your office he's saying
the words out loud pretty much like I
will play out the scene and at least the
emotionality of it you know and and then
but you know and so I'll get that you
know I'll get that um you know so far so
if I have ten days to do a rewrite you
know the first six are usually
procrastination you know and then the
last for an hour television in four days
so you know I mean I mean that's true
and it's not true meaning that I was
looking about yes and you know and I
write everything out on a huge
whiteboard in my office and covers the
entire wall and you know and I'll in the
story will be all beeped out but then
I'll usually have you know I'll just
have like you know it looks like serial
killer sprawl on the side of it in terms
of like okay that's what that beat is
and so that when I when I'm ready to
actually sit down and put something on a
page you know there's been work done
yeah that is a lot of times you know
whether I'm driving or you know I'll
it'll it'll sort of come together in in
process and you've done it so much for
so many years I would imagine you
kind of trust like even if you're stuck
like okay you know I've been I've been
here before right
yeah it's interesting I always I do and
then I don't you know I met in fact this
less what do you do when you're stuck
well this last script it's funny I I
finished it and you know there were a
lot of changes that I made not
necessarily big arcs in terms that was
never gonna [ __ ] up you know the
narrative component right where it's
going but just changes and and I'll find
stuff that I'll be like oh what if this
happened that usually like I won't share
with anybody until they read the script
and they'll go oh but and not that I'm
gonna go an actor I'm not that I'm
keeping it from anybody it'll just
happen in in process right and I've
learned to embrace that stuff and some
of it works and something but a lot of
it does right so you know I'll being
processed with all that and you know and
and you know I you know I just sound
like a if you walk by my office it just
sounds like a you know ranting yeah like
a lunatic right and and acting the
scenes out and and having those moments
but I'll you know you know out of that I
forget what your question was sorry this
is it like how do you work your way out
of being stuck like alright writer's
block
that's not something you experience do
you think that's a [ __ ] or like how
do you yeah how do you push through
moments where it's not coming to you
it's not [ __ ] I think my blocks
aren't so much in terms of story as much
as nuanced right like you know in this
episode and breaking the third fourth
episode you know I had an awareness
about what I thought the arc might be
and realize that oh I have to soften
that right and and open it up more to be
more you know to be a bigger point of
view and so then I can go back you know
we're gonna do pilot research right so I
can go back into some of those scenes
and allow for that
right so plant that seed I can plant
yeah episode four
so that's sort of you know it allows you
know there's there's room you know
there's room to do that but I you know a
lot of that stuff is you know it's not
so much block as in how do I you know
knowing where we're going how do i shape
things to lay track to that you know and
without compromising what it's supposed
to be or without like leaning into you
know hey we're going someplace else
like finding you coming to distract yeah
like finding the balance of that it's
like a weird alchemy it really is it
really is and you still you'll find
you'll shoot this stuff you know and
it's always you know it's always
different when you know you you get the
cut you see the actors interpretation
well there's out what's on the page and
then you're they're shooting it yeah I
like well that doesn't look what I
thought and you know and there's what
you shot and trying to piece that
together in the editing room yeah so you
you and and you know I've learned to
embrace that and and and and really you
know revel in in you know what it
becomes and in look sometimes it doesn't
work and you have to go back and and
sort of assert a point of view that
wasn't covered to protect story you know
or character and but for the most part I
really try to let it be a breathing
living entity you know and and and let
other people's create a point of view
inform the show you know in terms of
interpretation and you know it's it's
the magic of you'll do a scene let's see
what can I use for an example like on
Suns right you'll do is seeing with
characters that never organically
perhaps would come together in the scene
like I remember writing a scene for
Jimmy Smits and the only way to get him
there to location was with
the unser character right you know so
putting him in a car with that character
as like what are those guys talking
about and then I realized oh [ __ ] they
both love the same woman right so what
is that scene gonna be like so you you
then have to go well let's see I have to
service where it's going right so you
know so let me you know I there's a you
know there's exposition I have to try to
lay in right and then but then you have
point of view right and then you know
you give that to actors like Dayton
Callie and Jimmy Smits and you watch it
and it's [ __ ] gold right because they
bring all of their understanding of who
the characters were and then you think
all right I get it's got to keep writing
scenes for those guys you know so that's
an example of like yes it serves the
story but you have actors and a director
that bring their interpretation of it
and you go oh man that's that's magic
right and and then you you you write to
that it's really why I don't you know
and the nature of production for FX is
you know allows for this but it's why I
don't like to get too far ahead of
production you know in fact I I cut it
way too close towards the end and but
you know because I like to be able to
get feedback from cuts as I'm still
writing the show because you'll like oh
wow that that really works right so how
can i how can I service that you know
and plug it into the story because those
two like so you're writing as you're
shooting yes yes yeah so then I would
imagine that that would that would that
would make it more important for you to
shoot as much in sequence as you
possibly could episodically right yeah
you can do well I would I never we don't
block shoot episodes which a lot of
shows do which means you'll have the
scripts and then you'll block shoot in
one location set up for the next four
hours yeah yeah I don't mean like that
but I mean obviously you can't shoot
sequentially but right but if you're
gonna want to be writing along the way
because what happens is gonna inform
what happens next right to the extent
that you could control that I would
imagine would be something you would
want yeah but it's hard you know for the
most part I really don't see cuts until
they're done like I'm not a guy that
really you know I don't really watch
daily we're like what's gonna happen
next episode Ali's is if like there's
something we're not sure about or if
it's a new actor and I want to see what
the dynamic is but what ends up
happening is you you know I'll see it
you know a cut of it fairly soon right
that allows me to then you know maybe
there's a you know whether it's the next
episode or the prepa sewed off to that
after that um it's it's in proximity
enough to what I've witnessed to be able
to incorporate that in you know I mean
it happened early on Suns with with
juice and TIG like putting those two
together was like comedy gold right
right so then you're just like how do i
you know how do i service that by the
way exploit those and krantz and go
absolutely alright so so with the shield
you work your way up like every year you
kind of get promoted so that by the time
we're at season seven you're an
executive producer on the show did you
feel and then you go right into sons of
anarchy your first show that you created
I mean you know that show was such a
massive success I mean it was a cultural
phenomenon is it still like the most
successful show that FX has ever had I
mean Oh easy it's hard to judge that
because the times in the dynamics and
the rules changed whatever it was yes
alright so yeah I mean looking back on
that yeah I can't you couldn't have
predicted that I mean what was your you
know your your anticipation and your
expectation like going into that
experience so the shield or the snow
going into Suns I'm like what did you
take from Sean right like what did you
learn from working under Sean for seven
years
mmm that you then put to work on songs
pretty much everything you know I
everything I learned in that room in
terms of telling story and breaking
story you know I went to school
and on Shawn and Glen Mazzara in that
writers room you know and and learned
you know learned how to tell you know
episodic stories you know I you know I I
didn't quite know you know by the time I
was done on the Shh you know what ended
up happening is you know I my last
season on the shield rather than taking
a money bump
I took a time bump because I was you
know I knew I was developing this show
and I said to Shawn look I don't want to
raise but I want to be able to throw a
couple days a week at this other project
and Shawn agreed and you know so I could
start to segue into sons and because
what I ultimately found out was that I
thought sons was going to air when the
shield finished and what they decided
they wanted to do was air them at the
same time so that first season of sons
aired you know you know with the last
season of the show I remember that so
that was it was kind of nuts right in
terms of time you know you suddenly what
I thought you know was X amount of time
got just crunched and so not only was I
doing it for the first time I was sort
of doing it with a gun to my head right
and and and and you can only imagine how
I react when I have a gun yeah well I
saw how you reacted more than a few
times
that was your coming-out party on the
shield like you're a member of a team
there and now it's all you yeah your
face but it was you know and and look
the the network tried to protect me and
you know they brought in a guy to sort
of help me run that first season who you
know I ultimately you know within three
episodes you know crushed him and
stabbed him into the ground because he
didn't get the show right yeah and and
he was a talented dude but didn't quite
know what I was trying to do and
you know and and then you know so it was
it was really it was crunchy man you
know and and look you know it's all fear
right so I'm not the kind of guy that
you know I don't I don't fade with fear
right I I set myself on fire and run at
you right so you know it was it was
bumpy man it was really it was really
bumpy and and you know it took us you
know and we I just you know we premiered
and we were up against Iran you know the
night of the show premiered Suns was the
night Sarah Palin spoke so we lot like
our air you know who can protect that
right so the numbers you know and that's
when people were before people were
Tebowing everything and recording
everything on the DVR they're actually
showing up in front of a TV and and we
got you know we got crushed and you know
but then you know we'd slowly you know
we you know we basically got hammered
that first episode but then we was just
as sort of frozen rope for a while and
then by episode six or seven we started
to bump up so that by the time we got to
the end of that first season you know we
were doing respectable numbers and
everybody felt good about where it was
going and but it was an organic build
you know yes and I think what's what's
kind of maybe not unique but seems too
unique to me is that there's this like
you know super rabid fan base that this
show developed like it's a very I don't
know how the demographic breaks down but
it's kind of like a you know when you
see it and these people like I just know
from like your Twitter following or
whenever you've retweeted anything I get
a glimpse that like these incredibly
passionate people who just like adore
this program and and and what do you so
what do you do what do you think you
tapped into that connected you know it's
interesting I I had to sort of shake out
all of that and look at it again you
know when I was getting notes on on the
on this pilot for Mayans
and and I realized you know we ended up
doing a massive like and we ended up
doing the same thing we did on sons we
did major recasting and we shot like 90%
of the pilot right and I remember that
it was Scott Glenn right I was the first
guy and you had to reshoot the whole
thing right and we sort of did the same
on Mayans and and I didn't I made the
decision not to direct the second pilot
just because a lot of reasons but I felt
like I was too divided you know I
thought it would be a good idea but
ultimately I you know I felt that it was
you know it was it was difficult for me
to take off the producer hat while I was
directing and that's ultimately a
shackle you know so but you know what I
was what I was able to do is is is is
take is sort of I had the opportunity in
in the in the reshoot to sort of take a
step back and look at what I was doing
that wasn't organic and what I realized
is that I was for an example we had a
character that was sort of a matriarch
character and I realized that I was
trying so hard to not make her Gemma
that ultimately she was two-dimensional
and it had nothing to do with the
actress it was just you know I realized
what the mistake was you know and and
even having that conversation with John
Landgraf afterwards in terms of you know
they tested the pilot and and it was a
limited testing and they only brought in
sons fans to test it and you know which
is a double-edged sword right you have a
you have a
you know a friendly room but a friendly
room with a lot of audience yes and a
lot of opinions right and and and I had
to remind John you know because it was
about you know the matriarch character
and you know and really reminding John
that you know we didn't come into Suns
thinking we were gonna get eventually
half our audience would be women right
it was a male coming off the shield we
were shooting for that male demographic
it was you know and we didn't say like
let's create these really strong female
characters to broaden the show base
right and so we had no expectation of
that and that just happened organically
and it was quite frankly it was the
nature of that world right that women
not you know unlike the Cosa Nostra the
women in in the MC world you know they
have a function they hold the whole
thing together pretty much spins off its
axis you know like these incredibly
strong women yeah and so that happened
organically had I tried to impose that
it wouldn't have worked right so it was
a reminding John that yes we want that
demographic but we have to find it
organically right I can't try to create
characters to tap into a demographic now
the minute you do that you're dead
you're dead and that's that's at odds
with your whole deal is like being you
know unapologetically as honest and as
sort of you know fearless and courageous
as you possibly can be right and the
minute you step outside of that and
start looking at you know trying to
analyze and here you're doing that but
it's got to be hard to preserve that yes
yeah and not or not lean on it right you
know and and I was so aware of that and
you know and we had a lovely actress and
and it had nothing to do with her
performance and but you know so
ultimately that character got extracted
and it really became this dynamic
between a father and two sons Eddie
James almost has the dad right so we
have you know it's a great cast and
so we you know and then the inverse of
Suns hell yeah a little bit yes son of
the two dads or the ghost of a dad yeah
so but you know but as I write this
second episode you know already
there are these organic avenues to these
strong female characters right without
but now they're happening organically
because you know they're coming out of
story and they're coming out of
character and it's not me trying to
impose the matriarch character right
that goes back to that thing you said
earlier about trying to be flexible and
and allow it to tell you where it wants
to go yeah right
and it's you know and you know it's and
you know much to the chagrin sometimes
of my writers and you know in terms of
breaking story and creating beats and
you know that'll change a lot when I do
my draft but you know the magic for me
and this will sound sort of psychotic
but and as if nothing else I've said
today it sounds like but but you know
like for me the magic happens when I'm
in those scenes right and I hear the
characters right and I and I I'm engaged
listening to them talk to each other and
taking them on this emotional journey
and and then and then looking at it and
you know and and go oh that's you know
that that character is this right that's
how she responded based on you know the
backstory we've created and the things
that have happened
that's the organic response to that so
you know you start to see these
characters that you know they always
start out through dimensional right they
have to right so you start to see oh
that's an interesting layer right that's
an interesting layer I always use this
as an example that and this is this is
really ballsy but I was like a staff
writer on on the shield and it was my
episode in Sean which grade we will
always be on set with her
and we had an actress who it was you
know that show sort of aired in post
9/11 right so we have an actress and in
my script it you know she opens she's
they're doing a surveillance you know
they're looking for somebody and they're
not going to door and it's a it's an
Egyptian guy so the character who was a
cop you know she had this really in the
script it was like a really strong
reaction right and the actress who was
you know you know really smart and civil
minded and you know I think her husband
was an ACLU lawyer like she had this
very open you know political agenda and
she's like well she's and I remember
coming up to me going Danny would never
do that and I just looked her wet but
she does and and then just that beat for
an actor to go oh I have to make that
adjustment that I have to adjust my
backstory and you know and then approach
it suddenly I'm approaching this
character from a whole different way and
it's really difficult sometimes for
actors I remember having a conversation
with John Hurt at one of the upfront
things when he was doing damages it
wasn't really a conversation I was
listening to John I'm sorry bill hurt I
was listening to way I'm hurt who was on
damages and it was a fascinating guy and
he was talking about the process of TV
and how it was so difficult for him
because he's used to getting a script
and looking at the arc of the character
and beginning middle and end and the
growth of the character and and knowing
what all the choices were so that he
would start and then all of a sudden he
would get a script that flew in the face
of choices he had made and it was really
difficult for him until he embraced it
in terms of like being to make those
choices on a fly like oh he's a guy who
does does that so then and it's not like
it makes anything else he's done
[ __ ] it's just another layer right
and it had to shift his whole
perspective
and how he he embraced it and the good
actors really are able to do that if you
know if you lock into really sedentary
points of view about a character and
think that the character is one way or
the character can't continue to grow
through the arc of a season or a series
you know you're [ __ ]
so that was a bit of a rant I don't know
it's cool but as long as it doesn't like
you set up this world and so much of
kind of what you do is setting a tone
like there's like there's a very
specific tone to the shows that you do I
got yeah I don't know how you
conceptualize that on Episode one so
everyone's on the same page that's got
to be challenging and then there are
certain rules like to the universe like
what is the code like you know your
shows are about you know a very specific
like sort of code of honor it seems like
you know and that may not be you know a
normal person's code but in that
universe it makes perfect sense
right and all those characters have to
like understand those rules and like
behave accordingly right right right
and it's family and it's you know
whatever it gets crazy in this outlaw
world but what I wanted to get out more
is is how did that work with like
Charlie Hunnam because it seems like you
had almost like a partnership with him
yeah always made this program you know
you have to I think you know ultimately
you know what I realized is yes I have
to have a vision right I have to stay
steer the ship but you know you have to
empower your actors you have to empower
your directors and ultimately it was
Charlie and I on this journey and you
know so and Charlie was very you know
you know it was very few times when
Charlie felt I was taking the character
in a direction he didn't agree with most
of the time it was you know figuring out
the best way to get there
you know and and he really you know and
in and you know Charlie trusted me you
know and ultimately that becomes you
know an important component for a
creator and a
is that there has to be a level of you
know trusting I'm going to trust your
interpretation of who this guy is and
you're gonna trust you know the journey
that I'm taking him on and not that
you're not gonna bump heads not that
you're not gonna have different points
of view but that ultimately you trust
each other's talent enough to you know
to take it with to where it's supposed
to go you know yeah so Mayans comes
comes out when is that premiering in the
spring
um we don't know yet they're still you
know they're still negotiating I'm
hoping that we can you know I'm hoping
we can fall into the old Suns timeslot
maybe and and and maybe end of summer
early fall but they're still it's still
all up in the air right now where we
start shooting mid-april you know and
we're a couple scripts deep right now
and you know we're in the we're in the
throes of it's exciting that it is
exciting it's terrifying a little bit
it's one of those things where you know
bastard was a blast and and I'm you know
I'm bummed and only and only you know
lived for you for one season but it's
been about you know it's been a little
over two years since I've been you know
I've been writing the whole time and but
I've been in it's been a while since
I've been in this production rhythm and
you're like how do I do this you know
how does this work and then you then
would have but you're the guy who like
can't sit still you hate it when you're
not working I know come on but it would
but ultimately what happens is you have
no choice
like you can't I'm like I don't know
what is this and then all of a sudden
it's sort of like in fact I've I was
supposed to go to New York this week and
go to they have the network has are a
little upfront thing and but I'm already
behind on scripts and it's you know and
it's sort of like that's what happens
you're like oh that's how I do it I
[ __ ] lock myself in a room and I give
notes and I write you know what I mean
it's like you just you you you know
there's a certain amount of wiggle room
where you can go what is this until it's
like all on top of you and you go oh the
sink-or-swim yeah focusing you like get
it done yeah
alright man we've been gone for a while
I want to be mindful of your time and
let's go but let me just there's one
more thing I wanted to ask you about
which is like how you make it work as a
husband and as a father you know it's
like you're collaborating with your wife
that has to be super intense and
challenging you know somebody who
collaborates from time to time with my
own wife right right that blurring of
the lines between you know personal time
and professional time yeah and then you
know making sure that you're you're
balanced out enough so that you can be
you know the dad that you want to be ya
know that's it's a great question and
you know here's what I generally I [ __ ]
it up all the time and it's really
important forces us to you know look at
our [ __ ] you know so I'm always sort of
you know swinging wide and then you know
bouncing off a wall and then coming back
and Rees entering and going oh that's
who I am that's what I'm supposed to do
you know and you know Katie and I had
bumps early on and on sons and then you
know we got into a rhythm and she became
very respectful of you know you know and
was able to separate you know some
things and and then you know and it's
interesting now not working together
because we did it for so long we did it
for you know I'm with bastard in you
know UK and and you know now she's doing
her sitcom and and you know so it's
interesting having separate lives again
but in a good way you know what I mean
and but balance you know there'd ounces
it's hard yeah it's like doing you know
trying to stay in that pocket of of
positivity and and being mindful is
always a challenge especially for you
know and I think I can sort of throw you
into the workaholic category you
it's we love what we do and it can
become all-consuming and you know but
you know I always you know I have this
amazing you know
eleven-year-old at home who who just
constantly forces me to resent her she
doesn't let me she doesn't let me swing
out too far yeah she rattles my cage and
say pay attention you know and you know
in a very Curt like fashion you know
what I mean the mirror is a man it is so
up and but she you know she's definitely
my my mirror and you know it just it's
been a game-changer in every area of my
life
good bad crazy and and beautiful right
and she's usually the thing that you
know causes me to you know fall off the
beam and then she's usually the thing
that puts me right back in the middle
you know but you know balances uh is a
struggle yeah you know I have tools that
when I choose to employ them give me
some you know but you know I I have to
usually get really uncomfortable before
I employ some of those tools you know
and it's interesting that you guys are
both mean you and Katie are both you
know artists that are you know so in
your creative vein you know it's like
Katie's amazing she's an incredible
musician she can do comedy she just you
know what she did on sons was just
mind-blowing like her range is
extraordinary right like she's just so
prolific in her output and then you have
you you know who has a very strong
conviction about the visions that you're
trying to manifest and you know normally
it would be you know one one person in
the relationship is that
kind of creative person the other person
is more of like the grounded anchor
right right now ya know it's really um
you know in terms of professionally it's
really you know I think we're equally
respectful and in awe of what each other
do so there's a lot of respect for that
I don't think there's ever you know
because we're of what we do and how we
do it and both you know and obviously
recovery and and and this other path
this higher minded path were both on you
know contribute to that but we you know
we're very aware of the you know the of
the respect that we have for each other
and and it's usually you know there's
very few professional hurdles you know
you know family stuff and personal stuff
always is is the nature of it but
there's always you know professionally
we've always sort of been very lucky in
that you know even what she's doing now
and and superior doughnuts and you know
she you know I think she Jones's
sometimes for Gemma and but you know but
she loves what she does and she does a
really good job and she elevates the
quality of the work tremendously and and
I'm you know I can look at things you
know that whole other medium with a
whole different you know through
different glasses that allow me to have
this same amount of respect for what
she's doing there as she as she did on
sons you know and I think that goes both
ways you know yeah that's cool you know
yeah I think you have that too man
you know yeah I mean it can be it can be
prickly at times like the the the the
journey has been to come to that place
of like respect and admiration yeah not
like trying to ply my
of what I think that person should be
doing odd you know it's like yes like oh
she's got her thing and like she's
[ __ ] good at it and like it doesn't
need like I can stand back now and just
like like respect it and revere it right
without having to get too involved in it
yeah you know yeah that's space like and
and the same thing like she can give me
the space right and it's and that's
easier said than done
you know what I mean like that is you
know you know for fear-based people and
I speak for myself you know it's hard
it's hard to trust that right and but I
think you know look I think time and and
time can remedy some of that you know
what I mean and and you know we we trust
a little bit more and but yeah it's it
really comes down to having that you
know having that trust and and knowing
that you know no matter what happens
that it's all gonna be okay in terms of
success and what show gets picked up
what doesn't happen who gets the job who
doesn't you know that ultimately you
know that's all you know those are all
gifts you know and and you you know you
take them when they come in and and sort
of be grateful for whatever they look
like you know yeah but the dynamic of
your relationship cannot be defined by
those things no or you're screwed
no that's that's correct that's correct
but I think it's it's learning you know
how to do that yeah that enables you
know because that can be you know that
can add there was external threats can
you know can rip a marriage in half
right right so uh you know
but I think it's you know I think it's
having the ability to know ultimately
that we're all gonna be okay
no I hope so man are we are we gonna be
alright we're gonna be alright alright
that good alright final thing if
somebody's listening to this and they
are they have a creative spark but
they're frustrated or they feel stuck or
they they they don't feel like they
really understand how to express
themselves whether it's on the written
page or in music or or in film like what
do you I'm sure you speak to young
creative types you know filmmakers
writers and the like like what is your
piece of piece of wisdom you know it's
easy to say this but my experience is
that you know one really has to remove
the editor from that process you know I
think so many writers and speaking to
writing specifically you know people are
you know so worried about doing
something that's going to sell or
something that people want to hear you
know so there's there's this need to
like generate something that's going to
be successful rather than generating
something that means something you know
and and once and when you when you
adjust that process to create something
that with a specific result in mind
you're [ __ ]
right so you write about things that
move you you write about things that you
know whether that whether being moved
means you know being enraged means being
you know you know in love you know
whatever that is you have to write about
something and from a place of I need to
tell this story rather than I'm gonna
write this to get this and I would say
98.7 percent of the people that generate
scripts and stuff in this town are doing
the latter they're writing something you
know for an end result of this and not
that it doesn't work for them but
creatively you know you're you know then
you're you know you're you're just you
know a two-dimensional machine it's
funny it's funny that that's the case
when at the same time we all kind of
understand like we there's a dearth of
really unique compelling voices like
who's the next for who has the voice
with that's what they're looking for
right looking for somebody who has
conviction as a point of view who feels
strongly about something and when that
when that is expressed honestly and with
skill that rises to the top right I
always tell writers when they say you
know I'm trying to write this you know
or you know I want to write the script
about this right and I say well why are
you writing a script about this and
they'll more often than not well it'll
go back to a specific project right and
I said now do you think somebody you
know said write about that you know I
said no that became the thing everyone
wanted to recreate because it was what
it was and it's your job to figure out
you know what means you know rather than
you know starting with the end result
you start from you know within and then
you know be that thing that everybody
else wants to recreate yeah you know and
it's hard for writers to wrap their
brain around that sometimes you know and
that's why I'd much rather take a writer
who is green in terms of process and and
and you know technique but who clearly
has an interesting point of view you
know because that's that's the goal
right the rest is just any hack you can
learn a three-act format right so you
know and and you know and there's a lot
of talented people out there but you
know even some of those talented people
get fall trap to what do I need to
create to get the job and
and then you're [ __ ] ya know and
ultimately the super awesome job they
want will happen when they are able to
get to that place absolutely expression
absolutely because anything else they
get in the interim is all gonna go away
and now you know what I mean because
it's not real or it's not based on
anything that they truly are inspired to
do you know I think all right man
think we're doing that thanks brother
feel alright I'm good man you good yeah
yeah I heard out no I'm glad we finally
got to a chance to do this man yeah I
appreciate it and you've you've you have
been a source of inspiration in my own
life and you've been there for me as a
friend and I appreciate you as a human
being and I appreciate the work that you
do so it was a pleasure and an honor I
did it a little bit more about it you
know and and tremendous respect for you
and and and your journey and especially
these last you know 15 20 years is
really I tell people about you all the
time and and tremendous respect for for
what you do and and you know as I you
know half-heartedly tried to mirror you
don't do that I think you're doing all
right buddy thank you I'm cool awesome
acida rank is how you track this man
down
hit him up let him know what you thought
of our talk but don't bug em don't piss
him off thanks brother
[Music]